[Music]  we're learning this morning that pop  singer Demi Lovato is reportedly agreed  to enter drug rehab after an apparent  overdose she's been hospitalized in Los  Angeles since Tuesday  Entertainment Tonight says Lovato's mom  has been with her the whole time an et  source says a 25 year old singer has  been telling her family she can get  sober on her own audio from Tuesday's  nine one one call shows that Lovato's  friends wanted paramedics to arrive  quietly at her home you should be hear  the sirens real soon no no no this is a  medical emergency I had I don't have  control over that this is definitely a  medical emergency for her when you get  there as fast as possible Lovato's  management team reportedly staged an  intervention about a month ago